hallo mein name ist lukas
das war meine wasserflasche wir schauen
uns heute gemeinsam häuser und wohnungen
an die wir uns alle niemals leisten
können werden
ich habe allerdings auch gesehen und
dachte mir die sind auf jeden fall
ziemlich wild als allererste starten
jedoch erstmal mit einem kleiderschrank
ihr seht auch gleich warum
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das war schon immer mein traum
dass man einen schrank öffnen
und dahinter ist nicht so ein kleiner
bereich wohnen was hin kann sondern ein
kompletter raum
es hat mir immer so harry potter oder
narnia vibes gegeben machen wir nun
allerdings weiter mit einer 20 millionen
dollar teuren villa in kanada
und typisch für kanada liegt dann
natürlich auch schnee ich wollte er auch
nach kanada aber da war dann halt leider
kanada
[Musik]
ich persönlich bin ja überhaupt kein fan
von so was also das hier ist ein raum
der nicht dafür gebaut wurde meiner
ansicht nach dass ich selbst ich darum
wohl fühle sondern dass ich möglichst
viel platz aber möglichst viele menschen
und das hier würde mich auch ein
bisschen stressen also dass überall noch
so führungen keine ahnung was also das
ist natürlich alles geschmackssache aber
es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt machen wir
nun allerdings weiter mit einer 12
millionen dollar teuren villa in
vancouver
[Musik]
perfekt das einzige was wir gezeigt
haben war der rolls royce der
lamborghini und der eingang
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn man sich nur den materialmix ja
anschaut ist das voll und ganz 100 mein
geschmack ich hätte vielleicht noch die
einfahrt so ein bisschen aus so helleren
steinen macht wie beispielsweise hier
das finde ich sehr sehr geil aber sonst
ist es komplett mein geschmack also mit
dieser bruch steinwand und den
integrierten lichtern und dann dieses
schwarze das sieht sehr sehr wild aus
sich dort vor allem bei nacht aber das
hier verstehe ich nicht so ganz
da sind überall kleine
[Musik]
wo normal wild wirklich geisteskrank
wenn du in new yorks oder raum höhe von
fünf metern oder keine ahnung was da ist
hast das ist unfassbar dieser stadt wo
platz einfach nicht vorhanden ist was
ich allerdings trotzdem nicht ganz
verstehe beziehungsweise was ich nicht
mehr vereinbaren könnte wäre wirklich
dort damit zu leben
alle leute
drumherum in den hochhäusern können bei
dir reingucken
du zahlst so viel geld im achtstelligen
bereich
und jeder kann mir die reingucken das
fand ich nicht so geil aber das ist in
new york hat leider vorprogrammiert
[Musik]
diese villa kostet 14 eineinhalb
millionen euro und steht in la caleta
also bei malaga in spanien du hast
wirklich das ganze jahr über mildes
perfektes wetter und es gibt auch noch
eine sache die ich ändern würde und zwar
dasselbe wäre dass der boden ich mag so
fliesen nicht ja es ist total easy und
blabla aber wenn ich so viel geld in die
hand nehmen würde würde ich richtig
schön breit ist weiß es holz verlegen
aber was ich sonst richtig wild daran
finde es das hier
einfach diese natur mit drin so riesige
palmen die ja locker irgendwie 67 meter
hoch drin sind in einem haus und das
hier das ist nicht einfach so wie es
jeder aktuell macht kommen wir neben dem
marmor küche und schmeißen es da rein
und auch nochmal ins bad und ich hab ich
da so satt gesehen ich hasse marmor
irgendwie aber das finde ich richtig
cool das ist so designmäßig alles
perfekt abgerundet alles ist in einem
ding und ich tue so als wäre ich star
architekt
[Musik]
dieses appartement in new york ist
vielleicht 50 oder 60 quadratmeter groß
also weniger als ein zehntel von allen
wohnungen häusern die wir uns die bisher
angeschaut haben ich habe aber trotzdem
mit reingenommen einfach deswegen weil
activated hinten modeler furniture also
ein bett du kannst mit einer stimme
sagen beispielsweise herbert kommunen
bei der welpen und dann fährt das
darunter wie schlau ist das bitte sein
bett nimmt immer vier quadratmeter weg
wenn nicht sogar noch mehr
also das ist wirklich eine klasse idee
[Musik]
35 millionen dollar villa in los angeles
und das soll jetzt nicht dumm klingen
wir wissen alle dass unsere wohnungen
oder wenn man noch zu hause wohnt unser
kinderzimmer oder das haus der eltern
tauschen würde dagegen ist ja klar aber
wenn ich auch wieder an der stelle so
viel geld in die hand nehmen wollen
würde ich das nicht geil
das ist so als wenn sich da die
innenausbau architekten und so gedacht
hätten body haben echt viel kohle hier
konnte machen einfach nur was teures
rein ich finde da jetzt keine liebe drin
klar dass hier sieht unnormal geil aus
du hast da die natur guckst du bei los
angeles und damit den schwarzen mann mit
dem pool und so das sieht sehr wild aus
aber das hier da würde ich mich einfach
so fühlen wie in so einem kalten museum
was einfach nur teuer ist
[Musik]
überhaupt nicht mein geschmack
muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben dass sie
dir so aus als würde ich ins weiße haus
reinlaufen hier würde ich mir denken ich
werde irgendwie mag war spielparadies
für kinder und hier
70 unter der bodenhöhe
das heißt wenn er irgendwie dreck liegt
und das kann schon zu 100 prozent mal
vorkommen draußen und kleiner winterfit
mir ist alles in die augen
[Musik]
ja okay und normal geile aussicht new
york dagegen sagen das ist die geilste
aussicht die es gibt unter den kost auf
25 einhalb millionen dollar also das
muss irgendwas können aber das hier
das wird sowie weiß ich nicht in so
einem konferenzraum und von wegen hey da
sollen sich jetzt 40 geschäftsleute mal
hinsetzen er sage auch keine liebe drin
[Musik]
einfach nur geil
ich verstehe es nicht warum ihr dann mit
einem teuren auto vorfahren müssen weil
ich glaube leute die sich wirklich für
das haus interessieren ist es egal ob
werbefilm jetzt auf ein auto vorfährt
oder sowas aber dass sie finde ich
einfach nur wild also du siehst schon
hier der materialmix da aus dieser
weizen waren dann steht eine pflanze
fordern oben das holz und auch hier
dieses in der outdoor living
mit der natur zusammen das ist fällt das
könnte ich mir wirklich vorstellen aber
ich dann aber noch jahre
[Musik]
auch richtig krass
das den könig mir auch vorstellen was
ich besonders feier ist einfach dass
hier
alles schönen weichen weiß nicht sondern
hochglanz weiß und dann so eine art
beton cremeweiß und dann vor allem mit
diesem ding da oben drauf wie sieht das
ja hier schon dass man da oben alu matt
schälen kann
aber das ist nicht so ist von wegen ja
da sind dann glasscheiben ist ein
wintergarten sondern es ist offen aber
so was kannst du uns deutschland halt
einfach schlichtweg nicht bauen weil das
wetter hier nicht passt
[Musik]
was von außen hier weil ich das haus
übertrieben es kostet auch nur vier
millionen und steht in maryland also
irgendwo in amerika aber von hier weil
ich das überhaupt und wirklich krass ist
wieder aus mit den ganzen lichtern und
so generell bringt einem nicht so viel
also es gibt echt ne menge aber wenn man
dann rein geht um das haus das so
aussieht wie mir einfach nur verarscht
vorkommen das ist einfach nur von
wenigen platz was willst du denn machen
alter wird damit dem golfcart
herumfahren oder auch hier du willst
doch nicht da da ein esstisch haben
direkt das tor aus gucken in einer
einfahrt
[Musik]
ab
das hier ist
einfach meine wunsch einfahrt
genauso werde ich auch bauen wenn ich
irgendwann mal ein haus bauen werde
einen geilen baum eingepflanzt darum
kiesel und da drüben dann sollen so
einen kanal und toskana siehst du diese
steine angeordnet dann kann es also
darum fall und er der eingang ist ja
auch brutale aus mit diesen lichtern und
so da auch wie das haus dann von dem
gartenhaus aussieht also so brutal
heftig
hat so ein bisschen arabische vibes
finde ich aber schon krass von inet ist
trotz mir das anders gebaut hat gesehen
das fand ich auch wieder viel zu groß
von drin
[Musik]
also was geschah direkt höhenangst
wenn er das so nah zum fenster läuft
das ist hoch aber
das hier zum beispiel wollte eigentlich
auch bei mir machen also ich baue jetzt
in einem monat im kölner wohnung um und
wollte im watt eine komplette moosmann
machen da habt ihr aber jeder von
abgeraten
feuchtigkeit und dann fällt da mal was
von ab auf dem boden und dann mit
saubermachen und alles mögliche aber
es ist schon cool aus finde ich an der
stelle wird das heutige wieder beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat wie ich hier heute auf tik
tok häuser und wohnungen reagiert habe
die sonst alle niemals leisten können
werden dann lasst trotzdem gerne daumen
hoch oder diesem video hier da aber
nicht ein kann ein und klickt auf die
blockierende weitere videos nicht
verpassen wollte und ich entlasse euch
jetzt ins wochenende mit noch einen tick
tock und einem geisteskranken badezimmer
in new york
[Musik]
[Applaus]